[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous plaît
tu sais c'est qu'un signal de courtoisie
jeune homme ça ressemble à ça c'est
court
amical c'est sûr que c'est ce que ta
mère voulait faire c'était pas ça non
[Musique]
c'est un peu difficile pour moi ces
derniers temps désolé
accepté mes excuses ignore le hacker
excusez vous aussi on n'a pas plu je
n'ai rien fait qui mérite que je vous
présente des excuses
[Musique]
y aller
est-ce que ça va madame j'ai
l'impression que l'homme dans cette
camionnette mais suit la rage au volant
es tu pour être calme et poursuivre son
chemin
je crois pas que vous sachiez ce cas une
mauvaise journée
mais vous allez découvrir
[Musique]
cet homme a volé mon trip je suis déjà
arrivé je t'adore c'est le téléphone d
qui ça je suis avec ton ami
écoute moi c'est pas mon ami ok c'est un
fonds curieux qui m'a attaqué
aujourd'hui c'est là de votre première
leçon commence données moment telle
faille attendre c'est téléphone
non impossible
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous voulez
je veux vous montrer ce qu'est une vraie
mauvaise journée et vous enseignez à
vous excuser et ça vous allait la
prendre par ma vie à danser la terreur
ont commencé à comprend fait longtemps
que j'ai compris les conseils des tracts
parce que moi je le suis
[Applaudissements]